now you ready to hear about some other
video games
let's hear what's next for world of
warcraft
[Music]
hello everyone thanks for joining us
today
no matter where you are world of
warcraft unites us all
whether you're exploring the shadowlands
classic azeroth
or another part of the blizzard universe
i'm glad you could make it
because we've got a lot of good stuff to
show you
but first let's start with some covenant
pride
carrion take flight
night bay let the hunt begin
necrologs to war
didn't they let's party
the world has thrown a lot at us since
the last blizzcon
and the thing that's really kept
everyone going on the wow team
has been connecting with all of you the
bonds we forge with our guilds
and family and friends and wow
are powerful and real as
wow enters its 16th year and blizzard
celebrates its
30th anniversary we're so grateful to
have the most dedicated
and friendly communities in gaming
let's recap the events in azeroth
in wow classic we fought an endless
battle for south shore and tauren mill
we banded together to open the gates of
encourage
and join forces to take down kel'thuzad
in his floating citadel of nexramus
in shadowlands we helped our covenant
recover from the anima drought brought
on by sire denathrius
master of the vinthir and traitor to the
pantheon of death
we survived the halls of tour gas and
crafted legendary gear in our efforts to
expel dinatrius
from his castle lair
but innocent souls are still wrongfully
being sent to the maw
they face an eternity of torment and
heroes like anduin
remain chained in its depths the jailer
continues to grow in power he's
preparing to break free from the maw and
complete
his plan to unmake the entire warcraft
universe
and sylvanas you may be wondering what
she's been up to
all this time today we're excited to
unveil
our first major content update for
shadowlands
chains of domination
look around you what makes you believe
you're not just a weapon
to achieve his end enough
join our cause or be made
to serve right now
you hold all the power
make your choice sylvanas windrunner
despite all our efforts
the mall continues to grow
what if dinathius's treachery is
irreparable
the premise is lost and bastion cannot
save the shadow lands alone
none of this should have happened
perhaps the winter queen could
a living soul seeks an audience
a mortal a king
by all our measures one who has spent
his life
striving for justice
one who would give anything to serve
his people
one whose heart is true
very well he may approach
step forward
my ascended have spoken of you
the king held captive in the mall
that prison could not hold me forever
why have you come to bastion
[Music]
you have a key that i need
you will release this soul
from your grasp no
he is bound to me just as
you would sought to buy
your own brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the vessel performed its part
flawlessly
three keys
then they will see
death was never meant
to be chained
that is so intense i know you probably
have a lot of questions about what you
just saw
and what it means for the next stage of
your shadowlands journey
later today my teammates ian and jeremy
will be telling you more
about chains of domination in our
shadowlands update
please check out the world of warcraft
channel to find out more
next i'm excited to share our upcoming
world of warcraft charity pet program
we've heard a lot from our community
about how much they love these pets and
the opportunity to give to a good cause
along with ideas to make the program
even better
so during this upcoming campaign you'll
be able to donate
whatever amount you wish to directly
support
our chosen charity once donations reach
our goal
everyone playing world of warcraft will
get a pet for their collection
as a thank you whether you were able to
contribute personally
or not and to make this a fun challenge
if we reach a stretch goal everyone gets
a second pet too
and here they are the first pet
is bananas literally he was originally
available to his select few back in
burning crusade era so we're excited to
give
everyone a chance to adopt him
and if we reach her a stretch goal
you'll also get daisy the sloth
she's an all new pet he'll hang around
your neck when you need a hug
your donations during this campaign will
go to support
the medical humanitarian organization
doctors without borders
also known by their french name
minnesota saul frontier or
msf they're an amazing group doing
important work
around the world we're grateful to have
such a generous community and we hope
you'll help support
this worthy cause we'll be sharing the
details about the charity pet program
on the world of warcraft website soon
so we've talked quite a bit about
shadowlands
classic players now it's your turn it's
my pleasure to hand off to my teammate
holly longdale she's a longtime wow
player
a veteran mmo developer and she's going
to tell us what's in store
for wow classic
hi everybody first i'd like to thank
all of you who have ever been part of
the wow community over the years
you know online worlds like wow have
been a huge part of our lives for
decades now
as a dedicated mmo fan and a developer
myself
i remember hearing that blizzard was
going to be making their own mmo
and i thought well i guess i'll check
out that beta
and sure we all call the game wow but
really wow i could not believe
i got bit by the mmo bug again
i was so excited to be able to make a
night elf hunter
and be like that famous dark elf ranger
from the books that i loved
i have to tell you azeroth was and still
is
a place i love to live since last year
i've had the great honor to work
alongside the wow classic team
to bring these nostalgic experiences
back to life
for long time fans and a whole new
generation of players as a fan myself
i've had so much fun and well from the
simple things like
drive by buffing or making friends on
that
long haul from teldrassil to iron forge
all the way to the absolutely staggering
like when i jumped blindly through the
dark portal
and was running through hellfire
peninsula
heard this terrifying noise and then saw
the fell reaver biggest rumor
i had ever seen and i was very glad i
had vain death in that moment
and that's the thing about wow these
stories and experiences we all share
keep us coming back time after time
with that said i'm super excited to be
able to share with you
where our adventures are taking us
next
[Music]
you dare enter my realm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your foolishness has brought you to this
head
take my blood and choke on it get
to the outsiders i'll turn your world
upside down
brings back so many memories right like
exploring the fungal forests of zanger
marsh or
being awestruck at the chaotic magic
alive in netherstorm
the draenei in exodar the blood elves in
silver moon
i love playing them both do you choose
to enlist the aldor
or the scryers in your quest to fight
the legion
and of course we can't forget gathering
all your friends
to fight illidan at the top of the black
temple
i can't wait to relive it all with you
since the team first set out on their
own quest to bring the original wow back
to life
we have learned a ton about what players
are expecting from this kind of
experience we've also learned
when to keep things just as they were
and where we all might be open to some
changes
we're bringing all these lessons into
burning crusade classic
with our primary goal to bring back the
same feeling you had
when you faced the fell reaver for the
first time or
when you were digging through piles of
fel hound poop
of course we can't get this right
without you our incredible community
soon you'll be able to revisit outland
yourself when beta starts and
tell us what you think later all wow
classic players are going to be
presented with a meaningful choice
for each one of your beloved characters
do you want to move on into burning
crusade classic
or do you want to stay in the original
classic era
forever whatever you decide
you can do it all with your one wow
subscription
now i know i've thrown a lot at you but
don't worry
we'll be getting into the details in our
panel later today
so stick with us we'll make sure you
are prepared and now
we're going to hear what's coming up in
hearthstone